vielen dank für den freundlichen empfang
liebe gäste verehrte anwesende ich
wünsche ihnen ich wünsche uns allen ein
frohes neues jahr möglich ist ein gutes
jahr 2020 sein
ich wünsche ihnen persönlich gesundheit
glück und erfolg dass sie die ziele
erreichen mögen die sie sich für dieses
neue jahr vorgenommen haben uns allen
wünsche ich dass es ein politisch und
auch wirtschaftlich gutes jahr werden
möge
vor allen dingen ein jahr in dem wir
weiter stabilität und frieden haben
gerade nach den ereignissen der letzten
tage auf der weltbühne
das glaube ich eine neue priorität das
was am golf passiert hat auswirkungen
auf uns ökonomische mittelbar oder
unmittelbar aus sicherheits- oder
migrationspolitische wissen sie in den
letzten monaten bei den
regierungserklärungen im deutschen
bundestag die die bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel abgegeben hat da hat sie so oft
ein nahezu ausschließlich
außenpolitischen schwerpunkt gewählt und
wie oft hab ich mich gefragt warum
spricht sie nicht einmal zu den
innenpolitischen herausforderungen
unseres landes in diesen tagen aber
würde ich mir wünschen dass frau merkel
in der außenpolitik stärker erkennbar
wäre und dass er überhaupt wieder einen
außenminister hätten
und
und es ist ja gut dass wladimir putin
frau merkel zu einem gespräch nach
moskau eingeladen hat und dass frau
merkel eben angekündigt hat diese
einladung zu folgen
noch viel besser wäre es aber wenn frau
merkel ebenfalls nach washington fahren
würde um mit herrn trump zu sprechen an
dessen motive bleiben oft rätselhaft bei
damen und herren meine damen und herren
ich könnte jetzt noch länger über über
diese außenpolitischen fragen sprechen
ich will es aber jetzt an dieser stelle
selbst nicht machen weil ich sehe dass
hier von uns zwei experten im publikum
sitzen nämlich mein vize vorsitzender
der bundestagsfraktion alexander
lambsdorff und unser außenpolitischer
sprecher bijan djir sarai und ich bitte
euch jetzt einfach mal schnell nach
vorne schnappt euch anhand mikrofon habe
so gut geklappt mit dem talk das
wiederholen wir jetzt noch mal schnell
in der außenpolitik alexander lambsdorff
wieso
alexander lambsdorff und bijan djir
sarai der übrigens gerade ein ganz
spannendes gespräch über seine
perspektive als deutscher politischer
deutscher politiker mit persischen
wurzeln im fokus hatte
sehr lesenswert spiegel spiegel spiegel
was ach so es war so ausgewogen und also
also alexander wie ist die aktuelle lage
am golf ich glaube wir hatten die
situation die schon ziemlich dramatisch
ist die auch konsequenzen haben kann und
deswegen bin ich und du hast es eben
gesagt sehr enttäuscht darüber dass wir
einen außenminister haben der in einer
situation wo deutschland mitglied im
sicherheitsrat der vereinten nationen
das ist nicht zustande bringt dort eine
sondersitzung einzuberufen um
diplomatisch über diese situation zu
reden hätten wir uns das vorstellen
können
bei hans dietrich genscher guido
westerwelle oder klaus kinkel
die hätten sofort eine sondersitzung des
sicherheitsrats einberufen
das zweite ist
das zweite ist wir haben bundeswehr
soldaten im irak stationiert deren
sicherheit ist unsere oberste priorität
aber die bundesverteidigungsministerium
gestern morgen hieß es noch das
kontingent soll ausgetauscht werden
gestern nachmittag dann der
generalinspekteur sagt dann wird
tauschen doch nicht aus die männer und
frauen müssen dort bleiben können sie
sich vorstellen was das für die familien
dieser soldaten da bedeutet wir brauchen
eine verteidigungsministerin die
fürsorge und führung ernst nimmt die auf
deren wort verlass ist wo die bundeswehr
soldaten wissen woran sie sind meine
damen und herren ich glaube das ist in
gerade so einer situation absolut
zentral und einen letzten punkt will ich
sagen wir können nicht ausschließen dass
es zu einer vergeltungs eskalation kommt
und wir können auch nicht ausschließen
dass sie die region verlässt und
deswegen ist unsere aufforderung als
freie demokraten an dem
bundesinnenminister und an alle
bundesländer den schutz der jüdischen
der israelischen und der amerikanischen
einrichtungen hier bei uns zu verstärken
neben wir müssen ausschließen dass es zu
anschlägen gerade auf diese besonders
verwundbaren einrichtungen kommt
ich meine das problem liegt ja auch
darin wir reden heute über irak morgen
wahrscheinlich über den iran dann wieder
über syrien das hauptproblem ist diese
region ist nicht irgendwo auf der welt
sondern es ist unsere unmittelbare
europäische nachbarschaft und manche tun
so als hätte man damit nichts zu tun
aber das hauptproblem ist wir befinden
uns im jahr 2020 und es gibt bis zum
heutigen tag immer noch keine
abgestimmte europäische außen- und
sicherheitspolitik das ist das größte
problem aus meiner sicht daran müssen
wir arbeiten und
und bevor wir über die gemeinsame
europäische außen- und
sicherheitspolitik müssen wir überhaupt
versuchen in deutschland eine gemeinsame
linie zu bekommen
dieser bundesregierung gelingt es nicht
mal mit einer stimme in der außenpolitik
zu sprechen es gibt die position des
bundesaußenministers es gibt die
position der verteidigungsministerin
dann gibt es die position des schatten
außenministers aus dass der
fraktionsvorsitzende der spd mützenich
einige werden den namen schon mal gehört
haben also das ist das große problem
viele stimmen in der deutschen
außenpolitik und man ist in deutschland
ist kein zuverlässiger partner mehr in
der außenpolitik wir kommen definitiv in
der außenpolitik nicht mehr weiter und
wir finden auch die stadt und wir können
die probleme von heute leider gar nicht
mehr anpacken
ja
vielen dank für das aktuelle britin euch
danke dass ihr so spontan von strom ja
eben hat die linda teuteberg zum ersten
mal als neue generalsekretärin der
freien demokraten gesprochen liebe linda
respekt und gratulation zu deiner
premiere hier im hohen haus ganz toll
so gesprochen hast habe ich mich daran
erinnert dass ich selbst zum ersten mal
hier gesprochen habe vor genau auf den
tag zehn jahren moment soll der applaus
ausdrücken dass ich mich gut gehalten
habe
tatsächlich kann ich sagen ich habe
heute mehr haare als damals und
gaskammern
und das kann man in der tat nur von sich
behaupten wenn man ein bewunderer des
medizinisch-technischen fortschritts ist
aber ich erinnere mich an diese rede
noch sehr gut
ich habe über ein thema gesprochen zu
beginnen
das mir damals wichtig war und heute
unverändert wichtig ist ich habe
berichtet damals von einer allein
erziehenden mutter aus dem ehemaligen
jugoslawien die hartz4 bezogen hat
daneben aber gearbeitet hat um für ihre
tochter den musikunterricht zu bezahlen
und einer gemeinsam bessere zukunft für
die kleine familie zu erreichen und
diese frau hat seinerzeit mir berichtet
zehn jahre ist das her
wenn sie neben hartz4 neben
sozialleistungen eine stunde länger
arbeitet dass sie am ende des monats
netto weniger in der tasche hat als wenn
sie nicht mehr gearbeitet hätte zehn
jahre ist das her auch heute ist es noch
so wer mehr als 100 euro neben hartz 4
arbeitet muss von jedem euro zuverdienst
80 cent abgeben
es ist ein beschämender mangel an
fairness dass unsere unser sozialstaat
diejenigen behindert die sich aus
eigener kraft aus der bedürftigkeit
befreien wollen bis heute
zehn jahre her nichts passiert
die politische linke parteien die
sprechen jetzt über die abschaffung der
sanktionen bei hartz 4
für diejenigen die ihren verpflichtungen
nicht nachkommen
dann gibt es andere parteien gesprächen
über das bedingungslose grundeinkommen
bitteschön
wir sind im demokratischen ideen
wettbewerb aber wir sollten sprechen
über mehr anerkennung für diejenigen die
sich stunde für stunde aus ihrer
gegenwärtigen lage heraus arbeiten
wollen und deshalb sollten wir die
zuverdienstgrenzen von hartz4 so
gestalten dass jede stunde mehrarbeit
sich für jede und jeden auf persönliche
und das geht
ihre freunde
liebe liebe freundinnen und freunde
meine damen und herren das geht weit
über diejenigen hinaus die davon konkret
betroffen sind das ist eine frage der
leistungsgerechtigkeit insgesamt das ist
eine frage der erneuerung des aufstiegs
versprechens unserer sozialen
marktwirtschaft es fängt an den
zuverdienst von hartz iv
es geht dann zum mini job wenn der
mindestlohn erhöht wird dann profitieren
davon nicht viele minijobber weil sie
mehr geld im portemonnaie haben
die müssen zwangsweise wegen der starren
minijob grenze ihre arbeitszeit
einschränken
also sollten wir die dynamisieren es
geht weiter so kalten progression das
vornehme worte dafür dass die
gehaltserhöhung und die überstunde bei
facharbeiterinnen und facharbeiter
verstaatlicht wird die fortsetzung
findet es bei der grunderwerbssteuer wo
menschen an den fiskus viel geld
überweisen müssen damit sie danach noch
jahrzehnte die hypothek bedienen müssen
für vielleicht die erste
eigentumswohnung oder das erste
eigenheim in der familie
es setzt sich fort bei der neuen aktien
steuer von olaf scholz wo der kleine
aktien sparer der kleinanleger zahlen
soll
statt dass wir dafür sorgen dass wer für
private vorsorge geld zur seite legt
nach jahrzehnten die gewinne steuerfrei
haben kann und es hört auf bei den
gründerinnen und gründer in unserem land
die sich nicht um den aufbau den aufbau
des geschäfts kümmern können sondern wie
im alltag von ärgerlicher bürokratie
belastet sind um die menschen jedes uns
und genau dieses und
bei damen und herren um genau die ging
und geht es uns um diese menschen
damit kein missverständnis aufkommt wir
haben großen respekt vor denjenigen die
es im leben bereits geschafft haben aber
im zweifel brauchen die uns nicht unser
herz und unsere leidenschaft aber die
gehören all denjenigen die es überhaupt
noch mit fleiß sparsamkeit und
einsatzbereitschaft zu etwas bringen
wollen im leben die brauchen uns nämlich
weil die andere verbündete nicht haben
10 jahre 10 jahre begleitet mich
begleitet uns dieses thema jetzt schon
zehn jahre vor zehn jahren vor zehn
jahren
der stand der flughafen ber kurz vor
seiner fertigstellung
so lange ist das her und unabhängig vom
br
in deutschland tut sich doch nahezu
nichts verbraucher endlich das ist dort
die lehrer aus br und vielen anderen
projekten
wir brauchen endlich andere planung und
genehmigungsverfahren bei großen
infrastrukturvorhaben möglicherweise
sogar planfeststellung per gesetz damit
für das gemeinwohl wichtige
infrastruktur bei uns entstehen kann
das ziel muss sein dass das
planungsverfahren kürzer wird als es
danach dauert ein bauwerk zu erstellen
meine damen und herren
ein hehres ziel
vor zehn jahren hieß es es solle jetzt
90 prozent netzabdeckung erreicht werden
bei edge vor zehn jahren die tröstliche
nachricht an alle in brandenburg der
eifel und im hochschwarzwald ist bald
ist das vielleicht erreicht dieses ziel
viele worte der vergangenheit kennen
junge menschen gar nicht mehr denken sie
mal an das wort bandsalat das kennen die
älteren noch jüngere wissen gar nicht
was damit gemeint sein sollte die denken
dass irgendwie neues power food oder
irgendwas wie wäre das ziel
wenn wir in deutschland an digitalen
ministerium eine digitale strategie
bekommen damit am ende dieses neuen
jahrzehnt auch das wort funkloch nicht
mehr zum aktiven wortschatz junger
menschen gehört meine damen und herren
drittes thema
heute auf den tag vor zehn jahren haben
hier in stuttgart
atomkraftgegner demonstriert vor zehn
jahren jetzt am 31.12 ist hier in baden
württemberg das kernkraftwerk
philippsburg 2 abgeschaltet worden nach
zehn jahren ab jetzt importiert das land
baden württemberg kernenergie aus
frankreich und kohlestrom aus polen und
diesen fehler der vergangenheit sind wir
dabei zu wiederholen
eines der stichworte dafür ist etwa der
verbrennungsmotor wir sollten den fehler
nicht wiederholen
wir sollten nicht erst den verstand
abschalten und danach die technologien
abschaffen für die wir noch keinen
ersatz haben sondern wir sollten erst
technologie alternativen haben bevor wir
auf die herkömmlichen verzichten die wir
gegenwärtig noch brauchen
ja
vor zehn jahren haben wir alle hat die
deutsche gesellschaft die deutsche
wirtschaft haben wir zehn prozent
weniger steuern gezahlt als heute
die steuerquote ist um zehn prozent
gestiegen in den vergangenen zehn jahren
die ist jetzt viel höher als jemals in
der geschichte unseres landes sind
spitze weltweit die letzte steuerreform
datiert auf das jahr 2008
bis tief in die mitte der gesellschaft
hinein hat sich zum beispiel der
spitzensteuersatz vor gefressen
vor 20 jahren waren es noch 800.000
deutsche die spitzensteuersatz gezahlt
haben heute sind es bei drei millionen
menschen nicht nur millionäre sondern
inzwischen millionen menschen die den
spitzensteuersatz zahlen in den nächsten
drei vier fünf jahren bis 2024 wird
unser staat noch mal gegenüber heute
fast 400 milliarden euro zusätzliche
einnahmen erzielen voll zur mitte der
gesellschaft
es ist zeit verehrter anwesende meine
damen und herren dass wir das ziel einer
breitflächigen steuerentlastung vom
mittelstandsbauch bis zum
solidaritätszuschlag vom
sparerfreibetrag bis zur
grunderwerbsteuer wieder auf die
tagesordnung setzen
es kann ich nur
lassen wir uns
lassen wir uns nur das ziel setzen die
zusätzliche steuereinnahmen der nächsten
jahre zur hälfte an die menschen
zurückzugeben
dann sind das schon 200 milliarden euro
bis 2024 und damit erreichen wir noch
nicht einmal dass wir die steuerquote
deutlich auf das niveau des jahres 2010
zurückführen aber es wäre einmal ein
anfang denn es gibt nicht nur die
solidarität mit denjenigen die von
staatlichen leistungen leben
es gibt auch eine solidarität ist auch
eine frage der gerechtigkeit mit
denjenigen die von ihrer harten arbeit
überhaupt die staatstätigkeit
finanzieren müssen
auch das eine frage der gerechtigkeit na
und
naja und vor zehn jahren wurde norbert
walter borjans finanzminister von
nordrhein-westfalen der hat schulden
machen zur staatsphilosophie erklärt war
ein notorischer steuer erfinder und
verfassungsbrecher und wenigstens bei
dem problem dachte man wir hätten es
gelöst
aber er ist wieder da mit der genau
gleichen alten dts als steuer erfinder
wieder unterwegs jetzt die boten
wertzuwachs steuer liebe anna was eine
großartige nachricht an die menschen in
hamburg die eine eigentumswohnung
gekauft haben in dem teuren hamburg noch
jahre damit beschäftigt sein werden die
hypotheken bei der sparkasse zu tilgen
und die sollen jetzt noch zusätzlich
belastet werden durch die politik der
sozialdemokratie besser kann man nicht
verdeutlichen dass die spd sich völlig
abgekoppelt hat von den interessen und
bedürfnissen der mitte unseres landes
bei uns
und ja
und der der norbert walter borjans
unverändert noch die auffassung wir
müssen jetzt wieder mehr schulden machen
für soziale zwecke für infrastruktur
problem jetzt eben angedeutet bei der
infrastruktur ist ja nicht dass kein
geld zur verfügung stünde sondern eher
dass wir keine hinreichende zahl
baureife vorhaben haben und bei der
sozialpolitik kann man doch einfach nur
schauen wie hat denn herr walter borjans
das als finanzminister des größten
bundeslandes gehandhabt war damals ja in
der landespolitik auch mit tätig aber
etwa tv jahn verschulden gemacht das
stimmt aber nach seiner amtszeit musste
joachim stamp als familienminister mit
einer milliarde euro überhaupt erst
wieder die ruinös kaputt gesparten
kindertageseinrichtung qualitativer höhe
der zeit bringen
das ist doch der unterschied das ist
doch das ist doch der unterschied der
politischen konzepte norbert walter
borjans hat in regierungsverantwortung
bewiesen dass man mit schulden unsoziale
politik machen kann und joachim stamm
zeigt für die fdp in
regierungsverantwortung man kann ohne
schulden soziale politik mache meine
damen und herren das ist der unterschied
zu denen und uns
im letzten jahrzehnt haben wir viele
dieser großen herausforderungen nicht
beantwortet vielleicht müssen wir sogar
noch schärfer bilanz ziehen
dass manches problem sogar noch
vergrößert worden ist und für unsere
weitere zukunft ungelöste aufgaben hin
verlässt denke an die frage einwanderung
migration die ungelösten fragen der
energiepolitik rente mit 63 in einer
alternden gesellschaft
das erklärt sich vielleicht damit wie
der sap co chef christian klein gesagt
hat mit ängstlichkeit aufgrund der
chancen ausschlagen leid erklärt es sich
auch rente mit 63 einer gewissen
gefallsucht für einige wenige in der
gegenwart politische vorschläge zu
unterbreiten
von dem man in der sekunde wummern sie
ausspricht aber weiß dass sie nicht auf
dauer nachhaltig sind vielleicht hat es
auch schlicht mit mit einem aktionismus
an effekt überschuss der politik zu tun
der harald christ ehemalige
mittelstandsbeauftragte der spd der
gerade aus seiner partei ausgetreten ist
der hat in einem bemerkenswerten
gastbeitrag für das handelsblatt
deutschland diagnostiziert wir litten
unter einem ermüdungsbruch
er schrieb von gewissermaßen
selbstzerstörerischen dynamiken in
unserem land er machte insbesondere
dafür verantwortlich cdu csu und spd
dabei der befund von harald christ ist
blick auf den ermüdungsbruch richtig
aber wenn wir sehr ehrlich bei diesem
wechsel der jahrzehnte sind dann können
wir nicht bei einer oder bei den zwei
regierungsparteien unsere gegenwärtige
lage nur abschütten
und die dafür verantwortlich machen mal
ganz ehrlich sind zu beginn dieses neuen
jahrzehnts oder am wechsel der
jahrzehnte dann liegt das problem tiefer
das war nicht nur cdu csu und spd
sie haben auch einige jahre regiert die
grünen über das ganze jahrzehnt über den
bundesrat die politik in deutschland mit
bestimmt der wirtschaft auch in unserem
hoch geschätzt mittelstand wurde in den
vergangenen zehn jahren auch nicht nur
investiert es wurden auch viele gewinne
ausgeschüttet
weshalb wir im internationalen vergleich
eben nicht auch bei unseren
mittelständlern bei forschung und
entwicklung technologie da stehen wo wir
könnten ja so offen in welche richtung
sich unser land entwickelt die schlechte
nachricht ist wir können nicht einige
wenige dafür verantwortlich machen
die schlechte nachricht ist wir alle in
wirtschaft politik tragen irgendwie mit
verantwortung für die gegenwärtige
situation unseres landes die gute
nachricht aber ist wenn es nicht ein
unabwendbares schicksal ist dass uns
jetzt herausfordert sondern wenn wir
selbst unsere untätigkeit unsere kleinen
möglichkeit unsere ängstlichkeit sind
die uns im vergangenen jahrzehnt
gebremst haben da haben wir alle chancen
es in den 20er jahren besser zu machen
als in den vergangenen zehn jahren alle
miteinander
und jetzt
und jetzt schulze schuldzuweisung
sondern es macht ja keinen sinn jetzt
stellt sich noch die frage wie gehen wir
in die zwanziger jahre in denen sich
tatsächlicher entscheiden wird welche
weiteren weg unser land in diesem
jahrhundert gehen wird viele fragen
werden aufgerufen neue quellen des
wohlstands oder depression und abstieg
wiederversöhnung der gesellschaft oder
vertiefung der spaltung weitere
polarisierung digitalisierung als chance
oder als risiko ein neuer fairer
generationenvertrag oder ein sich
verschärfender generationenkonflikt usw
und sofort also viele große
herausforderungen neue weichenstellungen
die von uns allen
zumal der politik abverlangt werden tja
und wie war der aufschlag in die
zwanzigerjahre der politische aufschlag
angesichts dieser herausforderungen
dieser historischen fragen in den
bäckereien gibt es jetzt olaf to go
erst ein erster 2020 wird im kollektiven
gedächtnis bleiben als die einführung
der gurtpflicht und als ich mir jetzt
mal kaffee brötchen geholt habe seit
jahresbeginn die leute nimmt den ball
oft noch nicht mal mit vielleicht weil
sie den kaffee nicht umtauschen wollen
oder das brötchen aber besteht eben auf
hinaus will mal sehen ob ich hinaus will
dass das ist doch nicht die die
herausforderung dieser derzeit eine eine
solche pflicht weil an wie wie vielen
stellen haben wir dass das so so
kleinmütig gedacht wird man das gefühl
dass so ein richtiger tugend der
bescheidenheit gewachsen ulrike du hast
angesprochen wir sind im wettbewerb der
europäischen wirtschaftsnationen
inzwischen ganz unten angekommen bei der
wirtschaftlichen dynamik und ich habe
den eindruck politisch wird aus dem
verzicht auf wirtschaftlichen
fortschritt und wachstum jetzt geradezu
noch eine zukunft gedeutet als sei das
ein ein ziel an sicher gott sei dank
endlich sind für diese schreckliche
wachstum los das hängt im diskurs auch
damit zusammen dass wir oft warst du mit
ressourcenverbrauch verbinden man denke
an den bericht an den klub auf wurm aus
dem jahr 1972 als erstmals sie hat über
die grenzen des wachstums philosophiert
worden ist die geschichte hat aber
gezeigt der menschliche geist hat durch
spitzenleistungen durch
spitzentechnologie die tatsächlichen
oder angeblichen des grenzen des
wachstums immer überschritten und für
uns muss es geradezu eine staatsreform
seien weiter eine prosperierende
volkswirtschaft zu sein denn wir können
nicht nur über klimaziele und soziale
zwecke sprechen
wir müssen auch die frage danach stellen
wovon das in den 20er 30er jahren fort
folgende finanziert werden also brauchen
wir
dynamische boxer
wir führen führen debatten über ein
tempolimit dass das verbot von pick ups
bahntickets werden bis sie günstige
flugtickets ein bisschen teurer wollen
wir dann aus der perspektive des jahres
2030 sagen das soll es gewesen sein wo
sie nur den blick einmal weiter und in
die volksrepublik china schauen
die haben inzwischen 40.000 kilometer
einer hochgeschwindigkeits eisenbahn 400
km h wenn es sowas in deutschland gebe
zwischen hamburg und düsseldorf müsste
man im weihnachtsverkehr nur eine stunde
auf dem boden sitzen
wir haben so etwas nicht wir haben so
was sie und deshalb
und deshalb die befreundete meine damen
und herren
deshalb liebe freunde meine damen und
herren bitte denken wir doch mal
großstadt tempolimits stadt pick up
verbot stadt drehen an der preisschraube
bei bahn und beim flugzeug wir haben
eine europäische union wir haben
hunderte milliarden euro in den nächsten
jahren reserviert für investitionen in
projekte die europa zusammenbringen
sollen was würde den klima mehr helfen
und was würde europa mehr
zusammenbringen als eine neue
hochgeschwindigkeitstrasse von warschau
über berlin paris bis nach madrid denken
wir noch einmal groß in europa und nicht
immer nur klein musste ehrgeizig
in hessen werden jetzt die ziffernnoten
in den schulen abgeschafft nur können
teilweise abgeschafft werden ein
zugeständnis der cdu an die grünen um
die kinder vor der traumatisierenden
erfahrungen der fünf zu bewahren die
motive mögen edel sein
das problem aber ist wer die fünf
abschafft um die kinder von einer
traumatisierung zu schützen
der schafft automatisch auch die zwei ab
aus der die fünf geworden ist nachdem
man sich 14 tage auf den hosenboden
gesetzt hat aber aber mir geht es dann
los
wenn das abenteuer werden ziffernnoten
abgeschafft baden württemberg baden
württemberg und bayern haben sich jetzt
unlängst widersetzt einer stärkeren
koordinierung der schulpolitik der
bildungspolitik in deutschland ist zarte
pflänzchen der koordination in einem
nationalen bildungsrat wurde abgelehnt
aus süd- und südwestdeutschland
wie kann das verstehen niemand in baden
württemberg will qualitäts ergebnis wie
in berlin oder bremen nur das problem
ist nur feiert anwesen das problem ist
doch nicht die frage wo baden
württemberg im vergleich zu bayern steht
bei den gerade unlängst vorgestellten
neuen pisa ergebnissen
da ist deutschland abgefallen
im bereich der mathematik stehen wir
inzwischen wieder auf dem niveau des
jahres 2003 und in der frage lesen
schreibt kompetent sind wir
zurückgefallen auf das jahr 2009 als
hätte es das gesamte vergangene
jahrzehnt nicht gegeben und deshalb
müssen wir in deutschland in der
bildungspolitik wieder groß denken am
beginn der sozialliberalen koalition
1969 70 da stand das ziel die man damals
sagte der bildungsexpansion damit war
gemeint mehr menschen von den unteren
mittleren hin zur akademischen
abschlüssen zu führen heute brauchen wir
wieder eine bildungsexpansion sie muss
beginnen mit einer exzellenzinitiative
für die berufliche bildung wie muss sich
fortsetzen über die vernünftige
ausstattung der schulgebäude auch mit
digitaler infrastruktur und vor allen
dingen muss sie enden bei einem neuen
kompletten zweiten bildungssystem
nämlich dass für das lebensbegleitende
lernen denn was wir in bildung
investieren gibt die beste rendite auch
für die wirtschaftliche
wettbewerbsfähigkeit unseres landes und
öffnet lebenschancen
also wenn der wurf hätten den bus
stand debattieren wir gegenwärtig über
windenergie bürgergeld von der spd wenn
die energiepreise nicht teuer genug
wären der schon die höchsten in europa
haben wir es noch zusätzliches geld
zusätzliche subventionen mobilisieren um
die menschen vor ort zur zustimmung zu
bewegen um sie zu kaufen
ja deutschland im jahr 2020 in dänemark
entsteht eine eigene insel eine
künstliche insel für
offshore-windenergie in spanien entsteht
das größte solarkraftwerk der welt die
denken dass in einem industriellen einem
großen maßstab wären wir in diese frage
ganz kleinteilig sind vor zehn jahren
bei diesem dreikönigstreffen hier habe
ich seinerzeit gesprochen über die
faszinierende perspektive klimaschutz zu
erreichen indem wir etwa in nordafrika
in der sahara photovoltaik auch mit
europäischer technologie und unserem
kapital fördern
jetzt ist das zum greifen nah wir
diskutieren über energieknappheit in
unserem land wenn es nicht klappt ist
dann ist es die energie wir haben
nämlich die sonne
die lösung liegt aber nicht alleine in
deutschland in unseren nationalen
grenzen sondern groß zu denken in europa
beispielsweise in südeuropa mit unserer
technologie mit unserem und europäischen
kapital in industriellen maßstab
synthetischen wasserstoff synthetischen
kraftstoff zu produzieren der uns die
energiewende hierzulande auch
erleichtert denken wir doch einmal groß
über unsere nationalen grenzen hinweg
nicht davon passiert
nichts davon nichts davon passiert ja
und wir diskutieren über die grundrente
und schließt eine impfpflicht ist alles
gut
aber das sind doch nicht die großen
herausforderungen die wir in unserem
sozialstaat haben oma als umwelt sei das
beschreibt das generationen verhältnis
so nicht dass das die perspektive die
die lebensrealität in der mitte der
gesellschaft bei der älteren generation
dass die sicherheits als umwelt sehr
gering
bei der oma ist doch ein ganz anderes
problem eigentlich heute und es wird
sich in der zukunft verschärfen bei der
oma ist doch die frage wie können sie
obwohl sie gut im leben gearbeitet hat
vielleicht sogar eigentum in der familie
hat wie kann sie eigentlich den
eigenanteil für ihr eigenes pflegeheim
noch stemmen
plötzlich doch die lebenssituation
vieler älteren hier in unserem land
nicht umweltdebatte und deshalb brauchen
wir
deshalb brauchen wir eine andere
sozialstaatsdebatte die beispielsweise
im bereich der pflege auch betrieblich
und privat die vorsorge für die pflege
im fall der bedürftigkeit neu
organisiert dastehen wenn ich am ende
einer diskussion sondern überhaupt erst
am beginn bei dieser säule unserer
sozialen absicherung da dürfen wir die
mitte der gesellschaft nicht alleine
lassen bei der rente für diskutiert über
die rente mit 70 als ob das noch ein
bild wäre das auf alle passt ein fixes
renteneintrittsalter für alle die
biographien haben sich doch fundamental
verändert und deshalb müssen wir unseren
sozialstaat neu denken es gibt nicht das
eine feste renteneintrittsalter für alle
es gibt nicht die eine feste arbeitszeit
für alle es gibt nicht das eine normale
arbeitsverhältnis dass wir als schablone
auf millionen menschen passt im
gegenteil die gesellschaft
individualisiert sich und deshalb müssen
wir auch unseren sozialstaat
individualisieren paul kirchhof sprach
einmal davon unser sozialstaat ist
gegenwärtig wie ein fäustlinge der
schützt zwar beschränkt aber die
beweglichkeit ein
manche empfinden den sozialstaat sogar
als eisenhand schub der ist kalt aber
schränkt auch die beweglichkeit ein
das ziel müsse aber sein unser
sozialstaat muss werden wie ein finger
handschuh der schützt aber beweglichkeit
eröffnet am ende dieses jahrzehnt
sollten wir einen enkel tauglichen
sozialstaat haben der sich an den
bedürfnissen der menschen orientiert und
nicht die menschen zwingt sich an seinen
strukturen im leben zu orientieren so
denken wir groß
denken wir
denken wir in diesen fragen groß
deutschland braucht bei diesem wechsel
der jahrzehnte eine regierung die die
durch startet bloßes absitzen bis 2021
reicht nicht mehr
die kernaufgaben müssen jetzt sein
wirtschaft und innovation
das sind wahre worte nicht von mir
sondern von markus söder sie haben es
gelesen gestern in seinem interview mit
der bild am sonntag
markus söder hat recht mit dieser
aufnahme
was haben wir gegenwärtig angesichts der
herausforderung für eine regierung die
spd will am liebsten schnell raus und
wieder eine linke lehre vertreten zu
können und wir haben auf der anderen
seite eine koalitionspartner csu deren
vorsitzender offen in einer
sonntagszeitung dem wirtschafts und der
forschungsministerin das misstrauen
ausspricht wir haben eine
sozialdemokratie die in den nächsten
monaten aus profilierung versuchen wird
die union zu erpressen um zugeständnisse
zu machen oder ein exit aus dieser
regierungskoalition zu finden ich kann
hier nur sagen und bekräftigen wie
unsere position ist die cdu csu die
sollten sich nicht von der spd zu
irgendeiner törichten neuen schulden
politik erpressen lassen
es gibt im parlament alternative nicht
weiß wie unpopulär dass ausweislich
aller umfragen ist weil die menschen an
stabilität interessiert sind und den
regulären wahltermin im jahr 2021 sehen
wollen dennoch angesichts der lage der
spd angesichts der situation dass
inzwischen ja auch die unionsparteien
angesteckt werden von dem
erosionsprozess kann man nur sagen es
ist alles besser als dieser status quo
auch eine zeitweilige
minderheitsregierung oder auch neuwahlen
in diesem land in die haben keine zeit
zu verlieren
wir sind da bereits liebe freundinnen
und freunde hier waren und wir sind
bereits zur übernahme von verantwortung
wenn die politischen inhalte stimmen da
stellen wir jeden tag unter beweis
in unseren drei regierungsbeteiligungen
in den ländern
momentan wird allerdings eher geschaut
nicht auf vergleichsmodell innerhalb
deutschlands sondern gegenwärtig schaut
die politische klasse nach wien
auch ich dort gibt es eine neue
koalition türkis grün oder ja deutschen
technologie schwarz-grün klima und
grenzen schützen
steuern senken das erscheint auch
manchem in deutschland attraktiv
ausweislich war der leitartikel der
vergangenen jahre nun klima schützen in
österreich ist etwas anderes als in
deutschland
klimaziele in österreich gegenüber
unseren in deutschland ambitionierter zu
gestalten ist paradoxerweise
realistischer als bei uns denn als
alpenrepublik hat österreich
traditionell alleine mehr wasserkraft
und auch mehr bio energie als wir
insbesondere die frage grenzen schützen
steuern senken ist interessant das haben
die verabredet aber grenzen schützen
steuern senken
das ist in deutschland nicht an den
grünen gescheitert sondern bereits an
der merkel cdu insofern ist die
übertragung österreichische verhältnisse
auf deutschland nicht ganz so einfach
zumindest gegenwärtig paradoxerweise
werden wir ja in unserem land etwa in
der frage der migrationspolitik und
selbst noch nicht mal einig unverändert
blockieren die grünen ja etwa die
einstufung der maghreb staaten als
sichere herkunftsländer um die
asylverfahren und um die abschiebung
verfahren zu beschleunigen damit sieht
die behörde
auf die wirklich schutzbedürftigen
konzentrieren kann unverändert
blockieren die das und jetzt versucht
die union im deutschen bundestag dieses
eigentlich zustimmungspflichtige gesetz
am bundesrat vorbei irgendwie im
deutschen bundestag zu beschließen mit
allen politischen und rechtlichen
risiken damit die damit verbunden sind
da wir selbst in deutschland manchmal
auf einen nenner kommen in der
migrationspolitik
obwohl wir die hauptlast in europa
tragen sind von einer paradoxen
situation dass große deutschland das die
hauptlast der migration in europa trägt
muss jetzt auf den erfolg von sebastian
kurz hoffen dass er in der lage ist in
der europäischen union den gordischen
knoten in der migrationspolitik zu
durchschlagen
ich halte das für ein armutszeugnis für
die versammelte deutsche politik meine
damen und herren
nichtsdestoweniger trotz auch die
unionsparteien in deutschland die haben
sie natürlich orientiert auf
schwarz-grün liest man in interviews
hört man so sind auch schon die
politisch inhaltlichen konzeption
friedrich merz wird friedrich merz hat
vorgeschlagen den spitzensteuersatz zu
erhöhen als vorweggenommenes
koalitionsangebot an die grünen und
jetzt gerade beim klima paket haben wir
schwarz grünen live erlebt union und spd
haben sich verständigt auf eine de facto
ist es das co2 steuer die mit zehn euro
beginnen soll pro tonne und dann hat die
union mit den grünen verhandelt und dann
wurde der einstieg steuersatz von zehn
euro sofort massiv erhöht das ist eine
premiere in der deutschen geschichte
verehrte anwesende bevor eine steuer das
erste mal erhoben worden ist haben die
grünen sie bereits schon erhöht und das
die perspektive von schwarz-grün dennoch
träumt mancher in der union von einer
koalition mit den grünen
denn die ist machtpolitisch so attraktiv
wie es heute einer koalition mit der spd
ist
denn spd und grüne haben im grunde
machtpolitisch nur die rollen getauscht
der unterschied nur ist die grünen
stehen noch weiter links als die
regierungs spd
wer also von schwarz-grün heute träumt
der wird wie in bremen aufwachen mit
grün rot rot meine damen und herren um
daraus erwächst uns eine politische
aufgabe nämlich in ländern und dem bund
dafür zu sorgen dass unser land weiter
aus der mitte regiert wird
unglaublich
und in dieser situation spüren dass
viele menschen die politische landschaft
ist in bewegung geraten
alte zuordnungen alte solidarität und
bindungen sind schwächer geworden und
haben sich ganz aufgelöst
vor dem reichstag haben unlängst
landwirte demonstriert nicht gegen eine
grüne landwirtschaftsministerin sondern
gegen eine schwarze
landwirtschaftsministerin
die haben sich gewehrt gegen die
pauschale verurteilung als klima und
umweltsünder
obwohl ausgerechnet ja die landwirte
über generationen von der natur von
ihrem grund und boden leben müssen
die haben sich gewehrt gegen moment
sie haben die haben sich gewehrt gegen
einen aktionismus jenseits
wissenschaftlicher evidenz muss ganz
schnell um verbote geht
sie haben sich gewehrt gegen deutsche
alleingänge der ihnen die situation im
europäischen wettbewerb schwerer macht
dagegen haben die demonstriert da fühlen
sie sich von keinem mehr vertreten und
hat sich etwas verändert ja wir sind
immer noch kritisch bei den eu
agrarsubventionen wollen dass solch ein
besseres system ersetzen das den beitrag
zum naturschutz angemessen und würdig
als die gegenwärtige subventions kulisse
das war in den vergangenen jahren und
jahrzehnten immer ein kritischer punkt
in den gesprächen mit landwirtinnen und
landwirten aber die situation hat sich
verändert natürlich haben wir da einen
kritischen punkt aber im unterschied zu
nahezu allen andern wenden wir uns gegen
pauschale verurteilung gegen aktionismus
und bürokratismus stehen für
wissenschaftliche evidenz in der politik
und haben respekt vor eigentum und
leistung das gilt überall aber eben auch
für landwirtinnen und landwirte daraus
erwächst neuen er
euro
oder ich lese in der frankfurter
allgemeinen sonntagszeitung unlängst von
einem opel mitarbeiter da geht es um die
situation der spd und dem wohl folgendes
wortlaut zitat zugeschrieben er und
seine kolleginnen und kollegen wählten
inzwischen aus protest fdp oder auf dem
ehemalige opel mitarbeiter wir sind
keine protest wir sind eine
gestaltungspartei aber dennoch betrachte
ich es als teil unserer
staatspolitischen verantwortung dass wir
politisch heimatlosen eine alternative
zu den rechtspopulisten bieten teil
unserer staatspolitischen verantwortung
jetzt gerade jetzt gerade haben wir
nachrichten aus der automobilindustrie
einer perle der deutschen wirtschaft
einen wachstumsbringer mit
spitzentechnologie gehört dass es zum
arbeitsplatzabbau gekommen ist kommen
wird das ist teilweise kurzarbeit geben
wird wo es an eine spitzen branche bei
uns ist 9500 beschäftigte allein bei
audi und am tag als diese nachricht
bekanntgegeben worden
das hatten wir eine regierungserklärung
der bundeskanzlerin vor dem parlament
und sie ist auf den arbeitsplatzabbau
bei audi eingegangen auf die 9500
stellen die 9500 familien die dort hat
jetzt ja auch eine sicher geglaubte gut
bezahlte beschäftigungsperspektive
verlieren werden und der satz von frau
merkel dazu war lapidar auch kaiser
wilhelm glaubte als das auto auf karmann
die rückkehr der kutsche was für einen
mangel an empathie gegenüber den
menschen die jetzt berechtigte zukunft
sorgen haben müssen wir können keine
subventionen versprechen das haben wir
nie aber wir können eines versprechen
das wäre aspect haben vor der leistung
einer ganzen industrie und dass wir
beenden die einseitige fixierung auf
technologien die beschäftigungsabbau zur
folge haben werden ich weiß nicht ob die
baden württembergischen liberalen mit
ihrer besonderen zuneigung zum
wasserstoff recht haben ich weiß es
nicht ich weiß nicht ob nicht doch der
batterie elektrische antrieb sein wird
ob es synthetische kraftstoffe sein
werden aber mit einer sache müssen wir
schluss machen dass wir uns einseitig
nur auf eine technologie konzentrieren
werden längst unternehmen wie toyota in
japan auf wasserstoff setzen wenn längst
die chinesen abgerückt sind von der
einseitigen fixierung auf die batterie
elektrischen antriebe dann können wir
den beschäftigten der automobilbranche
eines sagen mit uns gibt es faire
rahmenbedingungen für alle technologie
optionen und nicht die politische
lenkung darauf dass eine
schlüsselindustrie künstlich klein
gemacht wird
von sachen kaputt
was unser angebot
und das und dass das greift viel weiter
man sich die die facharbeiterinnen und
facharbeiter ansieht da haben wir in
deutschland so eine sehr merkwürdige
debatte so als als ginge es um
bedürftige um die man sich kümmern
müsste ich doch nicht der realität man
möge sich bitte mal die tarifverträge
der baden-württembergischen metall- und
elektroindustrie ansehen über wen der
bei facharbeiterinnen und facharbeiter
eigentlich sprechen
die haben nicht nur die sorge einführung
vermögenssteuer die im zweifel im
familienbetrieb den arbeitsplatz
unsicher macht und den geht auch nicht
nur um fragen des verzichts auf
sanktionen bei hartz 4 und haben ganz
andere alltagsfragen warum bleibt nichts
übrig von den guten tarifabschlüssen
warum ist die öffentliche schule in die
ich meine kinder schicken muss in so
einem problematischen zustand das sind
diejenigen die über jahrzehnte
funktionierende integrationspolitik
erlebt haben nämlich gegenüber
denjenigen die mal als sogenannte
gastarbeiter zu uns kam an der werkbank
da waren die kolleginnen und kollegen in
der industrie die besten
integrationshelfer da sind aber zugleich
diejenigen die auch sich von claudia
roth nicht die praktisch zu
beobachtenden probleme der integration
vor ort ausreden lassen und genau diese
menschen mit ihren sorgen die
vorankommen wollen im leben die arbeit
wollen die für ihre kinder eine gute
zukunft wollen bildung die chancen
wollen zb auch auf eigentumserwerb wie
es immer ein fiel sogar der bergleute an
der ruhe war am ende des berufslebens
das ab bezahlte häuschen zu haben wie
sind inzwischen in der politischen
landschaft heimatlos geworden und wenn
diese menschen eine politische heimat
suchen dann laden wir sie ein möge in
den medien geschrieben werden jetzt sei
die fdp die neue arbeiter und bauern
partei ich habe mir nie träumen lassen
ich habe mir
ich habe mir nie träumen lassen ich
würde meine vorsätze nach einer arbeiter
und bauern partei sein
es stimmt auch nicht wir sind keine
arbeiter und bauern partei so wenig wie
eine apotheke und unternehmer partei
sind wir sind eine partei der
politischen mitte und es ein irrtum zu
glauben dass alle facharbeiterinnen und
facharbeiter linke politik wollten und
alle landwirtinnen und landwirte rechte
politik wollen was die menschen in
unserem land suchen ist eine alternative
aus und für die politische mitte und das
sind die fragen demokraten das ist unser
anspruch
und so
und so verehrte anwesende sehen dass
selbst langjährige ehemalige
sozialdemokraten selbst auch diese
partie eine innere vielfalt oder man
könnte auch sagen eine periphere binnen
spannung gibt es unterschiedliche
persönlichkeiten und auch innerhalb der
sozialdemokratie sind menschen die eine
liberale perspektive haben die
fortschritts und reformorientiert sind
die sich der politischen mitte
verpflichtet gefühlt haben uns
verpflichtet fühlen heimatlos geworden
in der eigenen partei einer ist heute
hier bin ich stellvertretend für die
begrüßen möchte ich begrüße unser ganz
frisches neumitglieds den ehemaligen
bundestagsabgeordneten und rheinland
pfälzischen sozialminister der spd ich
begrüße den neuen freien demokraten
doktor florian gerster in unserer mitte
herzlich willkommen in der fdp
liebe freundinnen und freunde meine
damen und herren ich weiß auch dass das
für uns nur eine kommunikationsaufgabe
ist aber die ist nicht unlösbar
ich hatte die große freude und ehre 2017
in nordrhein westfalen die freien
demokraten in die landtagswahl zu führen
die cdu hat von der wahl der fdp
abgeraten
ich musste also aus eigener kraft in den
landtag zurück kommen und wir haben es
geschafft mit dem besten historisch
besten wahlergebnis bei einer
landtagswahl und den größten zuwachs
hatten wir nicht von ehemaligen wählern
der cdu
den größten zuwachs in nordrhein
westfalen hat die freie demokratische
partei von ehemaligen
sozialdemokratischen wählern erzielt und
deshalb gibt es einen regierungswechsel
in nordrhein-westfalen genau diesen weg
den müssen wir weiter fortsetzen
es geht nicht um jetzt ein paar prozent
moment noch es geht nicht um ein paar
prozentpunkte von den jetzt weiß nicht
wie viel prozent die spd gegenwärtig hat
sowas geht um eine breite mitte von
menschen die gegenwärtig auf der suche
sind die oft genug die fdp noch sehen
naja durch das brennglas von jahrzehnten
von images die auch unsere politischen
mitbewerber gegen über uns verbreitet
und erzählt haben dass ist sportiver
wettkampf aber jetzt sind auch unsere
sportiven fähigkeiten wieder gefordert
und deshalb liebe freundin freunde meine
damen und herren darf ich ihnen allen
sagen wir freien demokraten werden in
diesem frühjahr ganz aktiv darum werben
und zwar nicht nur über die geschätzten
qualitätsmedien sondern auch indem wir
vor dass
moment das war jetzt keine verhöhnte ich
bin ein anhänger der pressefreiheit
selbst endlich alles was die medien über
die fdp schreiben freundlich ist es
stimmt auch nicht alles übrigens aus dem
aus dem protokoll
nein wir müssen wir müssen natürlich
werben und zwar auch im direkten
gespräch und deshalb liebe freundinnen
und freunde einen tag vor dem tag der
arbeit wo die gewerkschaften rote fahnen
hissen am dreißigsten vierten werden wir
einen bundesweiten aktionstag der freien
demokraten machen jeder orts jeder
kreisverband und wir gehen vor die werks
tore um mit den menschen darüber zu
sprechen was ihnen wichtig ist und was
unsere politische antwort darauf ist
denn man kann nicht nur wahlkampf machen
von der couch und auf twitter wir wollen
und werden in diesem jahr zurückkehrten
das persönliche gespräch mit den
menschen um die menschen für uns zu
begeistern
unser anspruch
liebe freunde
das innerparteiliche fast nicht kurz das
vergangene jahr für die freien
demokraten ordentlich gelaufen
wir sind mit der letzten umfrage aus dem
jahr 2009 10 gekommen von zehn prozent
wir haben 5500 neue mitglieder gewonnen
haben jetzt über 66.000 mitglieder
stellt vertreten für die 5500 neun
mitglieder begrüßt sich unserer mitte
den ehemaligen chef von porsche
matthias müller über matthias auch dir
herzlich willkommen bei den freien
demokraten
wir sind mit linke steinhart
zurückgekehrt in die bremische
bürgerschaft das war hier mal so dass
das gelingt wieder gewählt zu werden
wir sind im europäischen parlament unter
führung von nicola beer stärker
vertreten als vorher wir haben bei den
ostdeutschen landtagswahlen unsere
stimmenanteile verdoppelt und wir wissen
jetzt es kommt wirklich auf jede stimme
an
denn zum ersten mal seit einem jahrzehnt
haben wir mit thomas kemmerich wieder
eine ostdeutsche landtagswahl
erfolgreich abgeschlossen
herzlichen glückwunsch
jetzt lese und höre ich gelegentlich
über die krise der fdp ist jetzt so im
vergleich der letzten jahrzehnte sie 10%
5500 neue mitglieder
nach zehn jahren wieder in einem
ostdeutschen landtag wenn das die krise
der fdp ist dann möge sie lange anhalten
meine damen und herren
aber spaß beiseite dass wir gegenwärtig
einen stabilen aufwärtstrend haben soll
nicht davon ablenken dass wir natürlich
auch ziele haben das ist eine gute
ausgangsbasis aber nicht der endpunkt
einer entwicklung sprach gerade über
neue menschen die wir gewinnen können
ohne dass die uns verbieten können und
müssten aber in dem sich die politischen
verhältnisse verändern
aber wir müssen uns fragen stellen wo
fünf jahre nachdem wir hier ein leitbild
beschlossen haben auch da
aktualisierungs bedarf ist das werden
wir tun
klar wir haben uns einen
orientierungspunkt gegeben der
orientierungspunkt unseres leitbild das
ist der einzelne mensch nicht
irgendeinem kollektiv nicht irgend ein
abstraktes wir der orientierungspunkt
unserer politik das ist der einzelne
mensch dessen recht wir schützen und
erweitern wollen im hier und jetzt auf
seine weise glücklich zu werden
das ist unsere orientierungspunkt
deshalb haben die ziele wie das
vorankommen durch eigene leistung
weltbeste bildung selbstbestimmung in
allen lebenslagen diese großen
reformprojekte der freien demokraten die
sind es unverändert aktuell aber wir
müssen nach fünf jahren prüfen ob nicht
auch neue herausforderungen auf uns
zukommen ob sich nicht die gesellschaft
und ob sich nicht die freien demokraten
in ihr verändert haben darüber
debattieren wir auch heute hier was ist
uns wichtig doch natürlich spielt die
schonung der natürlichen
lebensgrundlagen eine viel größere rolle
als vor fünf jahren als wir unser
leitbild seinerzeit beschlossen haben es
hat auch das nur am rande in unserem
leitbild auf und da möchte ich meine
partei ein laden in diesem frühjahr
genau darüber zu diskutieren der grund
orientierungspunkt des einzelnen
ist richtig aber wir stehen längst in
einen ideenwettbewerb ob und wie wir die
schonung natürlicher lebensgrundlagen
verbinden können
mit einer freiheitlichen lebensweise und
mit wirtschaftlichem fortschritt und
deshalb wächst uns auch da eine
besondere verantwortung zu wir wollen
und wir müssen die klima- und
umweltpolitik aus der falle des
aktionismus und aus den linken
politischen instrumenten befreien nehmen
wir klima und umweltschutz wieder mit
vernunft uns mit technologie und
marktsteuerung erreichen und genau
dieses ziel das schlage ich vor sollten
wir in diesem frühjahr diskutieren in
unser leitbild aufzunehmen als
aktualisierung
frank viel
darüber werden wir in aller offenheit
diskutieren weil wir eine ganz lebendige
vielfältige partei sind ich hab gelesen
bei freien demokraten gibt es jetzt
einen liberal konservativen kreis des
sächsischen bundestagsabgeordneten
herbst und unserem wahlgewinner thomas
kemmerich mein freund johannes vogel
spricht ganz offen auch wieder über
sozial liberal als politische standort
mein freund und kollege michael theurer
sieht sie selbst als verfechter eines
öko liberalismus und rudolf renschler
aber
ich will auch folgender punkt hinaus wir
sind eine eine vielfältige partei von
einer partei von individualisten aber in
unserer liberalen partei verbinden wir
vielfalt mit teamwork und deshalb
schwächte uns diese politische vielfalt
der perspektiven nicht sie macht uns
stärker und ich komm nicht betroffen ist
und ich betrachte es als ein privileg
das sieht diese partei und diese
fraktionen führen darf die trotz aller
unterschiede in den nur außen und
perspektiven in einem verbunden ist wie
keine andere partei sonst nämlich in dem
vertrauen auf die vernunft und das
verantwortungsgefühl in anderen worten
die freiheit eines jeden einzelnen
und deshalb ist das gemeinsame was die
freien demokraten verbindet viel stärker
als die unterschiedlichen akzente die
wir in der tagespolitik setzen das macht
uns stark und
für die bahnreisenden jetzt kommen wir
zur letzten drei minuten denn genau
diese diese mission die individuelle
freiheit zu verteidigen das wird in dem
nächsten jahrzehnt auch eine besondere
rolle für uns sein wenn man die
politischen debatten ansieht da wird
über verstaatlichung gesprochen
beispielsweise von bmw von von
wohneigentum
zumal über den den mieten deckel meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren liebe
freundinnen und freunde die garantie des
eigentums das ist ein eckpfeiler unserer
verfassungsordnung wer diesen eckpfeiler
an sägt der sorgt nur dafür dass niemand
mehr in unserem land investieren will
denn die voraussetzung von investitionen
aus dem in oder ausland ist die
rechtssicherheit die wir in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten gewähren kommt
jetzt kommen neue
neue fantasien der vergemeinschaftung
der sozialisierung des demokratischen
sozialismus haben wir nichts gelernt hat
heute bei k s gehört aus unserer
deutschen geschichte haben wir nichts
gelernt aus den entwicklungen der
vergangenen jahre des letzten jahrzehnts
zum beispiel in südamerika mit genau
diesen ideen ist doch damals der
sogenannte reformer hugo chavez in
venezuela ins amt gekommen ja
selbstverständlich hat er industrie
verstaatlicht aber das ergebnis war
nicht das ist der breiten masse besser
ging im sozialismus sollen es ergebnis
war vor elenden hyperinflation und am
ende autoritäre politik es sollte uns
eines leeren am sozialismus ist nicht
die umsetzung das problem es ist die
idee selbst die nicht menschenfreundlich
ist die meinungsfreiheit
die meinung die meinungsfreiheit ist in
unserem land natürlich formal garantiert
aber wie es mit der meinungspluralität
also der tatsächlich gelebten
meinungsfreiheit dem wohlwollen auch
gegenüber der oder dem andersdenkenden
in hamburg ist der bernd lucke als
professor gehindert worden daran seine
vorlesung zu halten
ich habe bernd lucke als
ard-vorsitzender immer politisch
bekämpft in spiegel gesprächen in
talkshows in reden
ich habe bernd lucke immer politisch
bekämpft aber genauso würde ich mich
immer dafür einsetzen dass er
ungehindert seiner allerdings falschen
thesen verbreiten kann
denn das hält unsere demokratie aus
das hält unsere demokratie aus fonic so
nett und nicht zuletzt haben wir im
vergangenen jahr alle groß gefeiert den
70 jahrestag der verabschiedung des
grundgesetzes wäre unser grundgesetz
schaut da steht ganz viel drin von
freiheit von schutz vor freiheit zu ganz
wenig steht davon verboten denn unser
grundgesetz hat ein menschenbild das ihm
zugrunde liegt das menschenbild des
aufgeklärten mündigen des erwachsenen
verantwortungsbereichen menschen und
dennoch diskutieren wir michael thompson
auf gezielte war eine vielzahl von
verboten ja klar wenn in berlin ab dem
30 zwölfter bereits geböllert wird dann
stelle ich mir auch die frage
menschenskinder muss das sein
aber bevor wir so was verbieten könnte
man doch auch an den gesunden
menschenverstand appellieren dass die
menschen verantwortungsbewusst mit ihrer
freiheit umgehen denn das gehört zu
einer liberalen verfassung eine liberale
gesellschaft die solche konflikte auch
mit sich und unter sich ausmacht und
nicht immer nur nach dem gesetz befehl
ruf und deshalb bleiben wir treu ein
gutes neues jahr